warst du hier schon kommen hier vorne
hin was durch ihr ja da war ich hatte
was ihr war da schon man hey leute netz
willkommen zum dritten hat waren wir
sind sie gerade noch immer im
freizeitpark und wenn ihr mal auf die
punkte von krankhafter schaute dann seht
ihr hier singleplayer wird dann seht ihr
er hat ordentlich aufgeholt
und ich habe meinen pool geschenkt aus
mitleid und jetzt hat er schon sieben
ich habe am anfang so wie du bist und so
geträumt so ja das wird am ende der
punkt sei der entscheidend sein wenn du
jetzt glaub ich ist das wirklich ich
muss jetzt wieder so ein stück weiter
springen machen alternativen hat die
leute länger gucken weißen erweisen
die weil das nicht dass sich leiter
sprünge übels wie die pest asse nicht du
ehrlich viele ich auch geschafft
ich komme da gar nicht hoch ich kann gar
nicht hochkommen vorauswahl ungefähr wo
bin ich denn hier ich bin bei
irgendwelchen betten aha teleportiert
ich einfach mal zu mir gleich ich habe
glaube ich noch ein schalter und eis
hier war schon mal dran
warst du rein zufällig in der höhle mit
allah war mit dem lava java wander
punkte weiß ich was von lafee und
pünktlich am punkt an der leiter jawoll
leiter oder ein schalter eine leiter und
neunten punkt haben schon zwölf punkte
da kann man nicht hoch man zudem täglich
zu mir los ich bin noch mal ne yo ich
habe auch einen schalter war doch hier
hierfür brauche ich die leiter ich komme
sofort also ich bin hier oben 8 welche
labyrinth hier finde ich hoffentlich
erwarte ich bin noch im labyrinth und
hinter mir ist wie ein krieg ohne ein
rad auch wieder zwei gas training von
jetzt neun nein
doch warum findest du über zwei und
nicht nur eine es ist doch verlief
warum hat die anfangself unnötig
gehalten und wird gleich in kuba mich in
die luft springen ich hoffe es doch
ich bin hier wie gesagt noch im
labyrinth ich finde den weg den ich raus
und ich soll mich allerdings laut dem
motto nicht worden
doch ich komme schon so freunde ich kann
da nicht raus man kann da nicht raus als
er diese komische lebten kontrakte ich
muss irgendwie so rum er hatte ganz
demonstrativ die der handel muss ich
irgendwie so rumspringen so jetzt bin
ich hier oben und jetzt habe ich keinen
plan wie es weiter geht so was auf doch
ich habe sich ab heute bist du ganz
ehrlich absolut ganz ehrlich ganz
ehrlich schwer
das war ein problem so gedacht gehen ok
also andere schalter zu finden ja ich
bin auch punkte jahren habe ich hier
noch punkte habe ich noch schalter
ja du hast mich jetzt aus dem labyrinth
rausgeholt und warte mal ich kann hier
noch ein schalter geben
beim ringen bringen er kann's mir eure
geben dauerndes eine truhe und punkten
punkten punkten wo fackeln der fackel wo
die bahn punktzahl hinterher
ich hab den schalter übrigens ja auch
noch warte ich in dem dünnen mal in
denen hier auch noch du kannst dich
damit besser aus bist du domaine du
willst einfach nur wieder auf punktejagd
gehen nein ich hab dir noch alle
schalter gegebenes machen hättet alle
gome der macht nichts konstruktives hier
auch das ist immer das gleiche aber zu
möglich sind während einer folgeprodukte
ok ok den hass wir schon die beiden
platz nicht mal eben noch mal hinten
du musst aber sowas immer aufpassen was
man sagt viele dem ist viel zu ernst
da gerät schon attraktive spinne muss
man schwerlich töten wirklich dass keine
chance gegen die ich weiß also auf
megaprojekt warnung besprochen wer die
ganzen schilder gesetzt hat und ich war
die ganze zeit auf dem server dann kommt
eine spinne an und ich hatte komplette
rüstung die hat einfach mal zehn minuten
lang nicht in ganzer angegriffen aber
ich tue alles wieder drauf gegangen bin
sehr froh hier komm ich verstehe ja ach
so du hast du dir schon gelegt nämlich
doch nicht das machen wir so weiter
machen wo waren wir noch nicht ich war
im labyrinth obwohl er war ich noch
nicht komplett fertig ich weiß gar nicht
was ich jetzt machen sollte ich komme
mit dem trabant hier ist ein geheimgang
aber da war ich dann schon also sprich
wenn du irgendwo runterspringen kannst
springen nicht runter wenn ich ihn im
alltag machen klingt das was ich
abfackeln aber bei mir ist alles hell
hatte tag times at data and wegen
gedruckt hatte aber ich geh mal woanders
hingehen das labyrinth ist ein anderes
rätsel genau weißt du schon auf dem
riesenrad ok dann gehe ich da mal hinten
hat ja nun nicht aber ich mag die idee
hier von der richtig weil der erfahrung
dieser diese ganz schön schillig diese
ganzen schalter die man dann immer
finden müssen so was alles ist gut
neben jobs geschafft wie geschafft ist
aus der ausgang ist einfach nur ein weg
zu sprüngen hier checkpoint rick wright
oft nicht runtergefallen
genau da war ich schon wo du jetzt
gerade bist harald dann schnallt und
zweitem den gemeinen karin huster button
hat schon gemacht da war ein punkt drin
in dem ein kart
ich bin hier gerade auf dem riesenrad
und ich weiß nicht genau wo ich hin muss
nein you need to get is leider natürlich
hast du dir schon geholt ich die leiter
und so was also genau das habe ich schon
gemacht sagt das doch ich bin jetzt noch
mal durchgestartet doch gesagt du
blödmann zeichen dauerhaft jetzt konnte
ich nicht mehr hoch doch da kommen sie
rufen und carrie howes und ich habe hier
ein blatt papier gefunden womit man
anscheinend ein haus und ich habe eine
schallplatte gefunden
das heißt beim riesenrad finde ich
wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr
das war dann schon alles hast du den
schalter gefunden
ja habe ich aber welchem gewöhnlichen
sondern nur ein blatt papier und das war
wahrscheinlich für einen wie des
carriers wie hier steht der ok ich bin
jetzt holzen
da hier gibt's die gibt's aber keinen
weg durch doch dahin ist etwas kurz und
frank rieger vom ins haus ich verstehe
das nicht ich wo war ich noch unter
diesen fatalen schwache warst du schon
in dem labyrinth in diesem grünen da
hinten in diesem wolle solle wolle
farbenen teil weil damals ich irgendwo
hinkommen ich meine auch nicht nähen
oder was ich wo bist du überhaupt gerade
in dem immer noch in einem letter
labyrinth
ich dachte bis dahin reingefallen das
eine loch ja bin ich aber damit immer
wieder rausgegangen jetzt bin ich bei
einem komischen wolle dingsbums da muss
ich da vorn als der name genau kommt
irgendwie raus natürlich kommerz ich
gehe zu diesen aber ich bin jetzt bei
diesem grünen jetzt stehe ich natürlich
okay ich habe ein gefühl hatte ich bin
um mein gott oh mein gott hirscher mario
nachgebaut
dann weiter wohl noch nicht
wenn er noch steht aber ich hab noch
nicht super mario teilen habe ich mir
auch hier warst du schon mal mit dem
boden
ja da wo du runter fahren muss genau bei
den roten
genau ok dann waren wir doch überall
ohne hier ach nee ist dass hier etwa das
ems carrie howes ich bin gespannt
bestimmt nein was denn ich höre auch
nein aber ich bin ich habe so lange weg
im oben goldene äpfel
ich hab so lange gebraucht oder diesen
komischen parcours lang zu dort sollen
und dann am ende komme ich einfach mal
auf so einen scheiß idee und denkst du
jetzt habe ich da schon alles so gut
geschafft mache ich mal alles setzen
einzug die letzten beiden sprüngen und
dann nicht runtergefallen
die ich würde ich nicht mehr richtig wie
doch doch ja genau aber wer über drei
punkte
ich habe drei punkte 16 punkte insgesamt
luca will ist noch da ok ich halte ich
noch gut auch weil du grad nur roboter
bittet mama muh hahaha geht wirklich
nicht immer wieder den punkt sponsoren
ok ich gebe doch lieber gesehen nein
doch jung gestern am rack an ihre bisher
nur auf die suche nein stimmt doch gar
nicht ich gucke gerade wo ich hin muss
jetzt zwei schalker glück wird
explodiert erstmal kripo ok coolen auch
nicht schlecht cool noch mehr no go back
up in komplettem as you have been idel
blätter somit ihre schön wäre es wenn
überhaupt nicht alle schalter nee nee
ich hab jetzt aber die leitern und kann
jetzt wieder raus klettern
irgendwie ich weiß nicht
aber soll ich mich ab orten mal genauer
an weil ich kann mir nur schwer
vorstellen kannst aus der vor sich hin
du kannst dich pforten rot rot soll am
vorbei gewartet bitte ist ein schalter
zwei punkte ich kann nicht umhin ihre
mit kommen das ist unglaublich da findet
er kommt durchs laufen die letzte
staffel wenn man den staffeln cannes
gewonnen da desto mehr punkte da darfst
du dich auch gerne noch mal selber loben
ja danke luca jani ich ja und war schon
der trojaner avant 3.0 habe jetzt auf
jeden fall ich habe zwei leiter ich bin
ganz ganz lange parcours gegangen
endresultat war zwei leitern und ich
glaube in der mitte hier geht's auch
hoch ist ein komischer holz sturm legt
nach oben und ich weiß nicht ob ich
jetzt hoch kann oder nicht er doch ich
muss da so rein auf jeden fall ja ich
weiß wo ich noch nicht war ach ja da
vorne weil ich immer jedes alter die du
hast zuerst mal zur pk zu bringen ich
habe erst einen schalter gefunden und
wir haben ja schon gebracht und wie viel
punkte
ja ich bin nur am rathaus ist mit denen
ich war vorhin schon mal kurz draußen
jetzt habe ich allerdings sei lockerer
aufspielen wir einmal hochspringer da
vorne hier alter bis jetzt werden kisten
eingesammelt was du hier schon kann man
hier vorne hin was du hier ja da war
doch was war da schon man dadurch die
ganze zeit herum hüpfen setzen dass wir
hier hier hoch wie ich muss da hin jetzt
ja ja deswegen da ich deswegen habe ich
hier die leiter bekommen
so du hast ne doch ich brauche dich
wieder unten
wie heißt du nicht gewusst wann machen
ich komme doch natürlich nein wir
brauchen die leiter hier brauchen wir
nicht wir brauchen die da oben nicht
halten brauchen wir nicht weil ich unten
ab ob sie arm so macht man das alter und
jetzt schon ziemlich ich bin die ganze
zeit nur am arbeiten
wenn du dir jetzt die punkte da oben
greift dann boxe ich sowas von bis zu 70
poliert versteht versteht was haben wir
nicht hier eine lore hier guck dir das
mal auch nicht losfahren wenn man das
das ist irgendwie auch in kiel
aber was meinen sie damit carrie howes
verstehe ich gar nicht ich war okay kann
ich nicht jetzt auch ankommt und ich
komme da ja und ich bin schon wieder
ausgefallen aber schon wieder so eine
trommel um ein kart strecke
ja man muss da rechtzeitig abspringen
weil ich ich glaube schon oder wir gehen
mal manuell hoch man einfach mal zu fuß
hoch gehen
genau
nein da muss man drüber springen da kann
man aber das schaffen wir auch das schon
ja oder nein ich habe es geschafft hast
du nicht umsonst effekt okay kann man
hier über 9 euro
ich hab's geschafft uhr ein glück alter
wie wie hast du das geschafft
mit viel anlauf und du mit deinem tpc c
da mir einige war ich vielleicht der
beste auch wenn ich nicht so der beste
guck dir mal die orangen hier an
nein ich bin geübt darin nicht nur ist
ich mache den zwei minuten hat und dann
habe ich mir etwas zu trinken nach hier
oben vorne war ich schon auch mal und
macht das erst mal schaffen wir jetzt
gemacht und am ende die eigentlich hört
man ja immer hier in der schüler auf das
man hier bei mir nachfolge schön an den
kakteen weitermachen kann aber geschafft
geschafft denn auch auf blickt er wollte
hab's geschafft beobachte mich mal
geschafft
was haben wir hier schöne punkte
nicht nur do och ne ganz ehrlich ja ja
ja ja ja ja
obwohl er doppelt ruhe steht mit zwei
pumpen und diamanten schon okay hip hop
ich hab jetzt jemand schuhe auch nicht
schlecht so hasst wie ich da gibt
einfach mal daumen hoch oder wenns euch
gefallen hat ich bin aus meiner ferien
wenn er mich hasst mich um damit in
weiter folge hoch wenn ihr mich nicht
hast gibt er folgende hoch
wenn wir euch wir gerade tag ist dann
hochgehen mir nach dass dann gebt im
ausland reisen man auch ein daumen hoch
und ich wette wir wissen wir in der
nächsten folge richtung werden müssen
doch getriebenen glaube ich ja doch
müssen wir ja nächste folge beim bhd ok
haut rein
mit os lebt noch